some people like to play games on the
easiest difficulty some like to play
them on the hardest so how about we
crank it up a notch and see if we can
beat the outer worlds without taking any
damage for the build I put a lot of
points into the body in mind and I
actually had to take one of them out I
believe in temperament which is in the
other section because of health regen
which we'll get into just a little bit
later and then the stealth and long guns
was for the skills to be honest I didn't
really know what to do for the
appearance I couldn't really think of
anything kind of witty for the character
so I tuned all the settings to the very
right to see if we could come up with
something and we came up with this
character so that will be our character
for the whole playthrough and if you
thought he was a male you're wrong
don't assume her gender what's wrong
with you so for the rules if I take any
damage
I must reload the safe you could do this
one of two ways one is to reload the
game manually every time you're hit or
two if you're lucky with the game that
you happen to attempt this on you can
set your health to one HP using console
commands and the game will kill you for
you so it's pretty easy to do it that
way this game fortunately does have a
console command mod list online as of
recent and we can set our health to one
using the command health percent dot
zero zero one that will set our HP two I
believe
zero which technically should kill us
but I guess it doesn't the thing that
stops us though is that this game has a
health regen skill which is in the
personality section like I stated so by
default we have to turn this down to the
lowest possible so that we get no health
regen just to make this a little bit
easier on ourselves but already in this
tutorial we faced our first roadblock
the game makes you take damage so you
can learn how to heal I tried jumping
from every angle falling from every
single height and anything that I could
think of and I could not live but I
think we can understand since it's the
tutorial and we haven't even gotten the
first gun of the game yet I think it's
fair not to count this after our first
gun we encounter our first enemies and
this is where stuff started to get a
little bit weird
apparently when using mods time-dilation
actually speeds up instead of slows down
making everything around you a lot
faster and this is cool the game braking
and something that we can't use and
continue on with so we had to scrap the
whole idea of the health command and
just stay at full health and I had
manually do it myself using quick saving
and quick loading thankfully my mouse
has two macro keys on it so this was a
hell of a lot easier just to putting
them to quick save in quick load but now
that everything is finally set up we can
finally attempt the run the beginning is
simple kill the dudes with the guns
first and let the melee wielders run at
you and use time-dilation to take care
of them
TTD would definitely come in super handy
for a lot of the gaming thus far and
it's going to help us a hell of a lot
ton at the very end of the game but
after the first couple people we're down
and we met lieutenant mercer but not
before i broke my leg and i had to
restart i had her in the private assist
me and by that i mean i sat in the back
and watched as they did all the killing
and we got onto the ship with ada and in
my opinion listen to the best music
piece that this game has to offer i
decided to take the hill instead of
going through the hole which had no
cover and there was a lot more guys that
way once we finish that up we go around
the hole and we make it to edgewater
i must have had some sort of hard-on for
Silas since I always do his graveyard
quest every single playthrough and I've
gotten to the point where I don't even
need the quest anymore I just know where
to go immediately it was also here that
I discovered that spades and shovels
were actually a weapon in the game maybe
we'll make a video on that all on its
own but after collecting the fees from
Abernathy Ludwig Phyllis and Conrad I
introduced a guard to a game of toss
ball I started levelling up a bit more I
wanted skills and hacking and lock
picking as a back-up plan which will get
to way later in the video with the
original plan being a lot of sneak and
long gun skills as usual we check in
with read gather Parvati and we talked
to vicar max I wanted to have companions
with me but I thought using them would
be too easy so I opted to keep them just
for the skills and I would be the only
one that would provide any damage they
would just look pretty and give me
skills the main quests that I usually do
in every playthrough is the thomas and
the grace one it for the deserters as
well as getting Abernathy's medicine
just so I could give it to someone else
for an extra bit of profit this requires
that we go to the community center where
I took many many attempts here
not to get shot most of the perks I'd be
using it would be all related to time
dilation this is basically going too
hard carrying me throughout the entire
playthrough and it's incredibly useful
on the way to get to Zoey blue a guy's
limbs off with one hit stunned me that I
even had this power capable within my
human body to do this so I was very
excited to see what we could come up
with later eventually we made it to zou
until I realized that I need some speech
skills to help convince her and come
back to the deserters but I also
realized I didn't have enough of the
required speech skills from the time so
I clocked her with the staff we made it
to the geothermal plant taking it a
little bit slower making sure that I
wasn't shot from a random robot
thankfully I did have a heavy weapon so
this would help me a little bit with
this section I decided to lure a lot of
the bots down this little hallway where
the stairs are I had enough hours in a
rainbow six and enough hate mail from
players from my doc spawn Peaks that I
knew I could get this done with ease
Parvati then asked me a mind-blowing
question afterwards we met Higgins again
turned the robots on each other and
navigated through the facility and put
the power to edgewater on the way back I
told grace about Zoe and gave Thomas's
manga so that we could leave Adelaide
instead of them staying there Ellie was
super pissed that I directed all the
energy from her corpse farm away to
Edgewater so just like Zoe I clocked her
with a hammer
I got praised by Reed and I did the book
quest for a vicar max and I was off to
groundbreaker at this moment in time I
was actually doing fairly well with the
bits so a nav key would be super easy to
achieve here I wanted to get one because
going to Cascadia when you're going to
monarch is a pain for a no damage run so
the easiest way to do that is to do Jun
leis quests before that we stopped by
Belle shells and I stole her signature
dead eyes sniper which this and the mark
2 variant will come in handy especially
in the end game we decided to take you
down up on his offer so we could get his
nav key for cheaper and I plan on doing
the board side anyway so this wasn't a
big deal Jim this quest actually sucked
a lot more than I thought it wouldn't I
didn't have the necessary speech skills
to convince Macready and his gang of
people that were too close to me to get
out of the area and let me through and
since they were so close to me I was
getting overwhelmed and it was very hard
to not take any damage with this section
but finally we managed to succeed but it
is damn near stressful one of the many
hard encounters that we would have
coming up soon afterwards I had a chat
with Hagen one of the people from
sublight and I'ma be honest I got about
a hundred hours in this game and on at
least five plus playthroughs at this
moment telling from my past videos and I
had no idea that this woman actually
gave you quests at this moment we had
over 8,000 bits so I didn't need to do
any of the doctor missions on Rose way
so we completely skipped that area and
it was as simple as getting a Dom seal
getting Ellie by rescuing her friend
from who down by convincing him that
since I got his seal he should help us
out too then I talked to Felix got him
on board and we were off to Byzantium
within a few minutes Parvati had a
question for max but vicar max
essentially used big brain word and
confused the [ __ ] out of Parvati and
also myself I was going to have a stern
talking with vicar max but I was so
creeped out by Martin in the background
with his blank stare that I couldn't
even get a word out we met Percy in
Sofia and did the usual quests of
double-teaming a cougar and an
underground basement and then releasing
a Trojan virus into Phineas computer
Byzantium will need to be put on hold
for a little bit as we have a war that's
about to break out a monarch which we
need to attend to so we go to stellar
bay tell grim - [ __ ] off as usual and
have a drink with Nyoka after getting
buzzed with Nyoka I decided to snipe
Sanjar before we left I told myself in
the beginning of this playthrough that I
was actually going to do the msi in the
iconoclast quest for more XP but I kind
of forgot about that so since the I
reminded myself after I had already
eliminated Sanjar I decided that I was
going to kill Sanjar and keep him dead
but keep grandma live for quest
progression
I got ambushed by some Raptor downs on
the way there and I absolutely merked
the [ __ ] out of one of them Devil's Peak
would definitely be tough there's a lot
of guys in the front area so I decided I
needed some help from the group c3 so I
rescued their leader by defeating the
mega man - Queen and they took charge on
the base I helped a little bit but they
definitely did most of the carrying in
this section the bottom floor was pretty
easy and the top floor was made even
easier because c3 actually comes inside
for the assist and that cleared
everybody out hyrum introduced himself
to me and we continue with the
iconoclast side of the monarch side for
the playthrough so we rescued Carlotta
by clapping the front guard using TTD to
eliminate the
rest of them and thanks to a perk we got
where kills restore part of the time
dilation we pretty much killed every
single person there except one guy
before they even got a chance to shoot
at me we then went to the printing press
even though I was injured I did have
some fun with this section cuz I wanted
to kind of explore what this galoop gun
I found did since I had actually never
gotten this before and any other
playthrough and having them float was
kind of really fun and took a little bit
of the edge off of this playthrough but
of course there are rules for this
playthrough so I reloaded before this
happened and decided to do stealth
instead my heart was practically out of
my body at this moment I wasn't really
sure where to move and I was definitely
going to be caught so I reloaded the
save out of sheer fear speaking of fear
the rafter Don's apparently don't like a
lot of noises since they ran away when
the alarms were off I was gonna kill
this last one that got left by his boys
in the back but I sympathize with him as
I'm always picked last for kickball so I
spared him with that done we returned to
amber Heights Parvati and Max were
arguing again we lied about seeing the
van noise because of laziness and we
returned to Hyrum to complete monarch we
were pretty much ready for the ending of
the game but I was doing some research
in between recording sessions and
discovered that there actually is two
guns that might help us with the run the
pink slip and the mk2 Deadeye sniper
that spawn at levels 24 and 22
respectively and I feel like we
definitely needed a lot more firepower
so we needed to do some quests currently
at the moment at this time by the
playthrough we have a hundred in hacking
and lock-picking about 80 in sneak in
about 70 and long guns which is really
sick so we got some really high numbers
at the moment I wanted to test on some
of the TTD effects so I slaughtered
everyone in my sight at groundbreaker
then I got shot from the side reloaded
the save and acted as if nothing just
happened and then went on my way this
was about one to two hours of me doing
random quests like getting a bank loan
for Ellie getting high off shrooms at
max you know the usual
we even starred in our own movie we did
continue the sublight quest line which
was really interesting we went to
Cascadia and went to a secret Rizzo's
laboratory katherine back at Fallbrook
mentioned that I should bring a team of
companions that it would be useful I
thought she was joking until I realized
that Ellie could actually set off the
air unit in the laboratory just enough
for us that we would be able to breed
the oxygen in the laboratory but the
creatures wouldn't
so that was incredibly helpful Max and
his holy hacking skills helped us with
the second part and before we left we
picked up the mind-control gun which if
I'm being honest was actually the only
reason I even did this quest line until
I realized that it's utter garbage and
it's not even worth it and I wasted like
an hour of my time we then made it to
hrs 1084 a small station within the
solar system where we got ambushed
luckily for me I have a hundred in hack
skill and this came in handy because the
robots did all the killing for me I was
excited to see where this would go until
Lilly had told me that aliens were
behind all of this captain in my humble
assessment his Hagan is insane so we met
with the doctor and I was given a couple
of options either kill her or spare her
I was going with the board side of the
ending anyway so I decided to spare her
and let her continue researching after
being blue balled by this shitty quest
line and we continued with the main
quest and got both options to the hope
which meant we needed to see Minister
Clark and get some chemicals from the
lab which is actually a lot easier than
I thought
we used the back route to get in snuck
out when we were done lots of long
hallways definitely made this super easy
for sniping from afar and we were right
at the point with the hope we then went
to the hope didn't make much eye contact
with Duncan again ran past all the
robots using the holographic shroud and
skipped the hope to Tartarus afterwards
was the prep I really needed a good
sniper rifle so we ended up actually
going with the Deadeye mk2 for its
increase in critical damage making it to
Tartarus who cleared out everyone we
needed to and this is why I chose the
board side since all the prisoners wore
like clothing so no need for armored
targets that wouldn't die in one hit or
so just like the Phineas ending after
clearing all the prisoners we made it to
the RAM boss fight I was going to use my
100 and lock picking and the 100 and
hacking to get rid of him or at the very
least use the other option I believe
that you need ad hacking for but I felt
that that was kind of a cop-out and I
actually realized that we didn't even
need it to begin with we snuck around
him used all the possible drugs I could
find and I sniped his back for a good
start I was hoping this would kill him
on the first try so I didn't have to
worry about the drones but I was coolly
wrong so our new plan was to use the
sneak attack run away snipe the drones
then finish off the rim
I couldn't go another round of drones
since they doubled in numbers and that
was way too many drones shooting at me
at one time this was definitely a little
bit stressful but we did manage to get
it without taking any damage whatsoever
once we finally finished him off we
waltzed over grabbed the card ran
upstairs 360 phineus in his bald spot
and beat the outer worlds without taking
any damage yeah let me know if you guys
think about this video in the comments
below this is actually a pretty fun
video to do like I've said with all my
other videos this was just very
different it was that it's probably one
of the hardest challenges of this game
with the constant reloading and quitting
and all that [ __ ] so that definitely
gave me a huge hernia but we managed to
clutch it out I think yeah I'd like to
be if you do enjoy guys subscribe if
you're new if you have any other
challenge ideas that you want me to do
in the comments below leave a comment
and I'll definitely get to them and
maybe even make a video out of them with
that take care guys to have greater day
and peace out
[Music]
you